in a lengthy letter posted on Instagram
Biebs doesn't apologize but God's
expressed his thanks writing I'm
grateful for the tours but most of all
I'm grateful I get to go through this
life with you so why did he cancel his
remaining tour dates
well Justin gives us somewhat cryptic
explanation me taking this time right
now is me saying I want to be
sustainable I want my career to be
sustainable but I also want my mind
heart and soul to be sustainable so that
I can be the man I want to be the
husband I eventually want to be and the
father I want to be
while some musicians have defended
Justin at least one gene Simmons isn't
having it rich
Kenda knows you're white I got white
privilege
Justin's team cited unforeseen
circumstances as the reason for his show
cancellations
according to reports those unforeseen
circumstances have ranged from
exhaustion to religious awakening in his
post Justin also references his quote
broken relationships saying they let him
dictate how he treated others
I let bitterness jealousy and fear run
my life could he be talking about ex
Selena Gomez she too is now referencing
her past relationships telling InStyle
magazine I was so young and easily
influenced and I feel insecure you want
someone to add to your life not to
complete you in the September issue
Selena also details her mental health
recovery last year like Justin she
canceled her to her while out of the
spotlight she sought treatment for her
emotional health I went away for 90 days
she says and it was the best thing that
I ever could have done I had no phone
nothing and I was scared but it was
amazing and I learned a lot still in
therapy
Selena also talks about her current
boyfriend the weekend saying I'm lucky
because he's more of a bestfriend than
anything else but in his interview in
the new issue of Harper's Bazaar where
he poses on the cover with supermodels
Adriana Lima and arena shake the
weekends more coy when it comes to its
private life saying I'm not in a rush to
let people know everything about me
mystery is always great
[Music]